Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Episode "Cari antwortet". Heute mit Janusz und
Moisés!
Moisés ist unser Patron und hat uns gerade jetzt spontan getroffen, hier bei den Niagarafällen, auf der Grenze zwischen
Kanada und den USA.
Dort sind die USA, hier ist Kanada. Er hat uns also extra in Kanada besucht. Und woher kommst du?
Ich komme aus Lockport in New York, USA.
Und wir fahren gleich weiter nach New York. Vorher machen wir ein kurzes Video für euch. Und wir beantworten wie immer
Zuschauerfragen. Heute aber live wir beantworten die Fragen von Moisés. Los geht's!
Moisés, was ist deine erste Frage?
Ok, ich habe
zwei Fragen. Eine für dich und die andere für Janusz. Die erste Frage ist: Ich weiß, dass du in
Kanada für ein paar Tage warst. Also, was haben die
Kanadier über Donald Trump gesagt?
Gar nichts. - Gar nichts? Wirklich?
Wieso sollten sie über ...
... ja ok, es könnte ein Thema sein, aber wir haben nicht
über Trump geredet. - Es ist sehr witzig, weil ich fahre nach Kanada zwei mal pro Woche, und wenn die Leute
(heraus)finden, (dass) ich ... oder wenn die Leute ...
- merken - Ja, merken, (dass) ich
amerikanisch oder Amerikaner bin ... die erste Frage, die (sie) immer
fragen ist:
"Hast du für Donald Trump gewählt?" - Ja? - Ja, und das ist sehr sehr
Ist es komisch? - Komisch,
in Wirklichkeit
frustriert es mich, weil in den USA sprechen wir nicht über
politische Themen mit Leuten. Das ist eine private Sache.
Das ist witzig, weil das habe ich von vielen Amerikanern schon gehört, dass
Politik viel privater ist als bei uns. In Deutschland zum Beispiel
sprechen wir gerne über Politik, und es ist
Teil unseres Alltags, unseres alltäglichen Gesprächs, aber in den USA, das haben mir viele
Amerikaner erzählt, gerade jetzt in diesen Zeiten, wo es mehr Spannungen gibt, und noch mehr
Uneinigkeit, versuchen die Leute das sehr privat zu halten oder reden nicht mal in der Familie darüber.
Und in Deutschland ist das überhaupt nicht so. - Für uns ...
yes, Politik ist wichtig, aber es ist eine private Sache.
Ja. - Ja. - Ja, ich finde das super interessant. Aber vielleicht kommt das auch daher: in Deutschland hat man viele Parteien
und viele verschiedene Meinungen und viele
Optionen, deshalb ist es nicht so gefährlich, darüber zu reden, nicht so schwarz und weiß, es gibt nicht
richtig und falsch, sondern es gibt viele kleine
Mittelwege. - Ok.
Ja.
Was ist eine zweite Frage, Moisés? - Also,
diese Frage, Janusz, ich ...
Warum hast du nach Deutschland ... warum bist du nach Deutschland gekommen? - Also, in meinem Land, in Polen, gab es
ein etwas ähnliches ... einen ähnlichen Zustand wie einen Bürgerkrieg. Das Militär und die Polizei
ha(ben)
zwei Jahre lang das Land regiert,
und als es vorbei war bekam ich einen Passport,
und bin dann geflohen.
Und
mir war egal wohin, Hauptsache
raus aus diesem Gefängnis. Unser Land war wie ein Gefängnis, und ich landete in Deutschland. Ich wollte aber nach
Amerika. Da aber meine Eltern und Großeltern in dem Part
gelebt haben, wo es früher noch Deutschland war
durfte ich
eine deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit bekommen. Und deshalb war das für mich sehr einfach in Deutschland zu bleiben. Und ich bin in Deutschland geblieben.
Und (als) du in Deutschland war(st), wie war die Transition? War es einfach für dich oder
war es sehr kompliziert und schwierig, () die deutsche Kultur zu, zu ... - Kennen zu lernen. -
Ja, kennen zu lernen. - Dich zu integrieren. - Ja, also es war sehr sehr einfach für mich, ich hatte
eine sehr gute Schule bekommen, ich durfte acht Monate lang jeden Tag acht Stunden lang Deutsch lernen, und
ich durfte dann später mir aussuchen, welche Ausbildung ich machen möchte
und
ich
lebte in eine(r) sehr hübschen
Stadt
in Deutschland, in Münster, eine sehr angenehme,
sehr liebe, sehr grüne,
fantastische Stadt, und das hat ..., das war sehr einfach für mich. - Danke, danke.
Haben wir alle deine Fragen beantwortet, Moisés? - Ich glaube, er hat noch eine.
Du hast noch eine Frage? - Er sprach von drei Fragen. - Ja, es gibt eine ... ja, ich habe eine andere Frage. Ich weiß, dass (ihr)
verheiratet (seid).
Die Frage ist: Wie
wie geht es in
Deutschland, also (ihr seid aus) verschiedenen Kulturen,
vielleicht ein bisschen
ähnlich, aber verschieden, und wie geht es in
(eurer) Beziehung? - Ah, ok.
Mit, mit ... - Ob unsere verschiedenen Kulturen Probleme für die
Beziehung sind? - Ja. - Das ist eine gute Frage, Janusz. Gibt es ein Problem zwischen Deutschen und Polen?
Ja, zwischen Deutschen und Polen, aber auch zwischen uns gibt es einen
Altersunterschied, und der könnte auch
unter Umständen zu einem Problem werden, aber ... - Ich denke an die Sprache zum
Beispiel, es gibt ... Du hast Deutsch gelernt,
und ich spreche Englisch, aber ich w(urde) in Peru geboren, und meine Frau w(urde) hier in den USA geboren,
und wir haben manchmal
Missverständnisse wegen der Sprache, also ich denke
an Sachen wie das in einer Beziehung. - Wir haben nicht so viele Missverständnisse, weil Janusz schon
fließend, fast perfekt Deutsch sprach als wir uns kennengelernt haben, aber ich bin manchmal ein bisschen
gemein, wenn er etwas in Deutsch sagt, was witzig klingt,
weil es einen Fehler gibt, dann mache ich Witze darüber. Und das sollte ich nicht machen. - Ja, nicht nur Witze, sondern sie
spricht das nach, mit diesem schweren slawischen Akzent: "@@@@"
und dann lacht sie darüber, aber - Das stimmt nicht!
Ich liebe das, ich mag das, weil für mich ...
Cari hat viele Gebiete, wo sie nicht lachen will, weil sie ist sehr sehr
feinfühlig, ja, und mit mir kann sie ein bisschen, sich ein bisschen
ausleben, dieses political Unkorrekte so ein bisschen, ...
Was laberst du da für Quatsch, Janusz? - Okay.
Also du sagt ... - Sie kann sich bei mir ein bisschen austoben. - ... ich bin so Deutsch
und so ernst, wenn ich Janusz nicht hätte, hätte ich gar keinen Spaß am Leben. - So ist es, ja.
Haben wir alle deine Fragen beantwortet, Moisés? - Ja, ich denke,
euch oder ihr
habt das gemacht. Wenn ich mehr Fragen habe, werde ich sie schreiben, ok?
Ja, unbedingt.
Und das sollt ihr auch machen. Wir werden, wenn wir dieses Video veröffentlichen,
auch bei Instagram Fragen beantworten. Deswegen klickt auf unsere Instagram-Seite. Der Link ist hier unten, und dort könnt ihr alle Fragen stellen, die
ihr habt, und Janusz und ich werden sie dann beantworten, heute Abend. Tschüss, und bis bald. Danke, dass wir dich treffen konnten. - Tschüss! - Danke. - Ciao!